yeah my parents were furious genetics
today we are gonna learn about our
genealogy or as I like to call it you
genealogy we're working with a very cool
company called 23andme they basically
read your spit and tell you where your
family is from who all those old people
were that bone if any of the try guys
find out that part anything else they
are going to celebrate like it's their
birthday it would be interesting if I'm
more parts of Europe because I only
really know about the German Irish
Scottish bit I will pay you a million
dollars if you have anything African in
your results today we're gonna go over
your ancestry importance we compared
your DNA to our 31 reference populations
and we assign you percentages based on
your genetic similarity to them all from
spit all from speck how much spit does
your laboratory get every day we have
over two million customers each person
is approximately two milliliters
that's a lot of stress I have a decent
understanding of my makeup but it gets
really hazy because of World War two
maybe I'm Italian maybe I'm French maybe
I'm I don't know any other European
countries I have a grandmother from
Germany I have two grandfather's from
somewhere in Russia who knows I'm pretty
confident today that I'm not gonna be
surprised like anything I've always just
been a Korean guy if there's one thing I
know for sure that I'm 50% in town I
don't know percentages no specifics 9/32
well 3/32 English 3/32 Irish and 1/32
that we don't know one of these is
Scotland yeah alright Zach so uh what
did you think your ancestry was I
believe that my entire family's
Ashkenazi Jew to be Jewish is something
that I'm very proud of I think it has
shaped Who I am and who I aspire to be
I assume we all started off in the
motherland Israel but uh a lot of people
claim that Zach you are 99.6% European
alright let's break down your European a
little bit
sure you are correct your 88% as a judge
idiot I thought I was full blood
[Music]
you are also Northwestern European 4.2
percent okay so that's broken down into
0.2% finish I'm finish finish and
Scandinavian people right the percentage
that's not asking Ozzy okay what is it
Iberian or Italian your part Spanish so
it could be Spain or Portugal so that's
just like one person of my family was
like [ __ ] it I'm gonna not marry a Jew
is that weird that I'm like disappointed
that I don't have more of a mix do you
always come across white people being
disappointed that yeah I wish I was a
little more spicy but I'm just like I'm
not vanilla more like hummus I guess all
right keep their up oh boy
I'm a white dude you know white dudes
aren't super complicated we probably
came from Europe I don't know anything
about this so what a rude awakening
maybe I don't deserve to know where I'm
from I don't know it's one of these
somewhere in there that's the book you
are in 99.8% guys why are you what are
you doing like this for it's very clear
that I'm the whitest man to be fair we
always joke about who the widest right
so now we're ever gonna find out
genetically actually is why so keep this
more white desert yes yes you have 0.2%
sub-saharan
I will pay you a million dollars if you
have anything advocate in your two
percent that comes into place sometime
between 1810 and 1720 I thought this was
real cool until I remembered what the
British were doing in the 1700s love it
happens I don't know if that was you
don't know if it wasn't luck could have
been like the food traders yeah really
good it's just good friends
fact is we'll never know spit will never
tell us that kind of thing this channel
yeah so you are 52.7% British and Irish
so that includes your Scottish ancestry
did you know though that fried chicken
originates from Scotland what if your
ancestors created fried chicken you tell
us that they didn't you are 3.7%
southern European 0.3% Balkan and then
3.4% broadly southern
I would say that so far all the places
you name love their food I think you'd
like to prove them everywhere don't you
that's true but the Asian countries are
too spicy for me typically so it makes
sense that I'm not Asian at all also I
don't look Asian you are a 0.4%
Ashkenazi Jewish maybe you guys can get
Burnett's bed together
maybe I was the little bit you needed
all right nod so what did you think your
ancestry was my mom's family is half
Italian and my dad's family is very into
genealogy so I know my genetics down to
the 30 seconds that's me your family has
a lot a lot about this are they gonna be
upset if you're not happy Thalia yeah I
put all my eggs in the Italian bath got
it so if I'm not half Italian I'm gonna
have to change my holiday traditions we
joke that he's the most white you're
correct you are a 99.9 so let's break
that down for you 15.6% French and
German yeah bro your fractions are
sections are way off
are you ready for your Italian oh yeah
you are 18.4% Italian that's really low
so you do have 15.1% broadly southern
European DNA which doesn't mean that
it's not Italian it's just we can't
pinpoint it doesn't mean that it's
definitely so exactly no it's very sad
for me you are 2.4% Iberian explains why
you're such a good dancer
you've got Native American likely again
not a proud data point but yeah another
data point
have you seen depictions of Thanksgiving
in children's elementary school
textbooks did you read what actually
happened to Pocahontas sadly you've got
0.0% Ashkenazi Jewish no sorry it's kind
of an exception even I'm over
okay so now it's time to go over e
Eugene's result now I will shade in the
country or countries my ancestors are
from done I just cannot imagine myself
being even any other Asian country all
their parents aren't 2% Korean and if
I'm not then my mom and dad can get a
very surprising call I'm just expecting
it to be Korean you are not 100% Korean
you are 63.1% Korean you are 19.9%
Japanese 19.99 my parents were furious
you are 13.1% Chinese what yeah 13.1%
10.1% a family's full of lies well these
are not insignificant numbers these are
like whole chunks of like huge parts of
relatives that's one eight one eight is
this the only the only way I can accept
this based on my family history is that
the Chinese and Japanese entering my DNA
are from like a thousand years ago
that's the only explanation that figs
I've only been told
bring crank ring Korean all the way up
for like since Korea was created on land
a thousand years ago would not leave
seventeen or thirteen percent most
likely a grandparent great grandparent
or second great grandparent who is a
hundred percent Chinese what what for
Japanese great-grandparents second great
grandparent or a third
great-grandparents was bull Japanese
Japanese how about that how do you feel
I mean I I'm just shocked I just I've
always just been told I'm Korean there's
like no other there was like no other
option do you think you're gonna tell
your parents yeah they're gonna say no
it's not true broken system bad math I
would have actually not been that
surprised if it was like five hundred
years ago or three hundred years ago but
in the past 100 years having a full
world Chinese and Japanese person within
my D
is really mind-boggling I'm telling you
I should like to sleep you guys are late
yeah you do that now this doesn't change
my perception of Who I am but it does
change my perception of where my family
came from look I'm not gonna stop eating
panettone at Christmastime just because
this tells me I'm only 18% Italian
genetics is different from culture that
is your cultural upbringing and that is
still really valid and strong I think
it's more important than your genetics I
don't honestly expect that I'm gonna
marry someone who's Jewish I probably
won't and I hope that our babies are
[ __ ] from everywhere someone from
here has to do with me someone from over
here has to do with me that's a bigger
picture of like human evolution right
like we're a lot of different things I
want to shade in every country on this
goddamn map five generations from now
hey guys want to find out if you're
related yes okay you guys might all hold
hands
they could not detect identical DNA
segments you you couldn't detect it
because the technology's not ready or
it's not there it's not there but maybe
if new technology gets invented give me
another - I got my spit I'm gonna spit
some more one two three yes wait does
that mean that Eugene can make all the
Japanese and Chinese jokes he wants and
he's totally clear one in the fifth and
one six weekends I don't know if it
comes for the African in the name one
out of every 500 joke is allowed to be a
little less sensitive
[Music]